merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur olivier marc l'ex monsieur le
ministre
samedi en début de soirée une bande
d'une trentaine de jeunes a débarqué
dans le quartier du plateau à juvisy
saccageant tout sur son passage
au total une vingtaine de voitures ont
été endommagées des halls d'immeuble
dévasté un appartement ravagé ces jeunes
étaient cagoulés armés de battes de base
ball de sabres 2 h
tout cela suscite évidemment une très
forte émotion chez les habitants de ce
quartier émotion d'autant que ces faits
se sont déroulés sur le territoire du
commissariat de savigny-sur-orge qui a
subi quelques mois à peine des attaques
d'une insupportable violence avec quatre
de ses fonctionnaires de police piégée
est attaqué au cocktail molotov
l'un des policiers grièvement brûlée est
toujours hospitalisé visiblement la
visite en grande pompe de votre
prédécesseur monsieur cazeneuve au mois
d'octobre ne semble pas avoir beaucoup
impressionné les voyous de ce quartier
une seule question se pose monsieur le
ministre comment est il possible alors
que nous sommes en état d'urgence depuis
430 jours que le parlement a voté à cinq
reprises la bsaa prolongation que des
bandes armées de battes de base-ball de
sabre puissent circuler librement en bus
en toute impunité sur le territoire de
la république
il s'agit de délinquants seconde à
l'hippisme n'importe quel groupe avec
des intentions criminelles ou
terroristes auraient pu se déplacer de
la même façon je ne vous demande pas à
monsieur le ministre de vous défausser
en faisant la coupe tabilité
hypothétique de ce que seraient les
effectifs à la fin du quinquennat de
monsieur fillon ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui est de votre responsabilité
est de votre responsabilité seulement
c'est le résultat de quatre années de
désarmement pénales systématiques la
parole est à monsieur bruno le roux
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
député vous avez tant à vous reprocher
que vous vous protégez avant même la fin
de votre question moi je souhaite vous
répondre sur le fond de cette affaire ce
week-end onze jeunes porteurs de barres
de fer et d'outils ont saccagé les abris
bus un appartement des voitures ils ont
été arrêtés par la police ils ont été
déférés relâché l'enquète se poursuit
aujourd'hui
il s'était débarrassé s'il vous plaît
j'ai rallumé respecter l enquête et le
droit qui fait qu' ils sont aujourd'hui
il y à une enquête et je vous dis la
détermination totale du gouvernement à
faire en sorte que les responsabilités
puissent être mises en oeuvre contre
ceux qui ont fait cela mais puisque vous
me parlez de la circonscription qui
comprend aussi viry châtillon je veux
dire que ce matin onze individus ont été
arrêtés
ils ont entre 17 et 19 ans ils sont
actuellement en garde à vue et ils sont
soupçonnés d'avoir attaqué les quatre
policiers
on aurait parlé tout à l'heure l'enquète
et je veux remercier tout les enquêteurs
qui ont mené depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois une enquête sur lequel nous avons
donné tous les moyens pour que soit
arrêté les agresseurs de policiers
tout comme tous les moyens seront mis en
oeuvre pour arrêter ceux qui sont les
casteurs dans la rue à juvisy ce
week-end alors je veux féliciter la
direction de la sûreté du 91
la série suit qui a participé à
l'opération et leur dire la grande
confiance que nous avons aujourd'hui
dans les forces de l'ordre pour assurer
la sécurité de nos concitoyens
il fallait quand même monsieur le député
une grande cécité pour avoir transformé
des postes en treize mille suppressions
pendant votre quinquennat
ce qui amène quand même à la situation
que nous connaissons r si monsieur
ministre